the federal government is terminally
broken right four years
where he was going to drain the swamp
the swamp is deeper than it's ever been
right our lives are still controlled
under 180 000 pages of federal laws
rules and regulations administered by
440 separate agencies and two and a half
million unelected Federal bureaucrats
right the federal debt has gone up to
the point now that our children's
Children's children's children are still
going to be paying on it right so
nothing got done our tax money is being
taken paid to overpaid civil servants
most of them make more than the governor
of our state right where that money in
turn is funneled back into Democratic
coffers that are out there now openly
pushing neo-marx's Theory and philosophy
as public policy the the so he can
promise whatever he wants to promise but
at the end of the day the federal system
anything connected to it is going to be
tainted just like it is and we might as
well be Tethered to the Titanic headed
to the bottom of the North Atlantic